rusia desafío a occidente a través del
gigante del gas ruso gazprom
moscú cumplió su amenaza de interrumpir
el suministro de combustible a polonia y
bulgaria lo hizo ante la negativa de
estas naciones a pagar en rublos como
exigió el kremlin espíritu mega su gasto
la suspensión del gas de gazprom es una
flagrante violación de su contrato en un
chantaje al utilizar un plan contractual
de pago en rublos a través de terceros
que no garantizan los suministros ni el
dinero de los búlgaros
en respuesta a polonia dijo este martes
que intentará imponer multas
contractuales a rusia
26 gigas vamos a pagar en rublos por el
gas ruso hacemos un llamado a todos
nuestros socios en la unión europea no
sólo para que no paguen por el gas ruso
primero para crear un mecanismo aduanero
especial para el gas y petróleo
provenientes de rusia para que rusia no
pueda adquirir fácilmente otros
mecanismos en segundo lugar apelamos a
introducir las llamadas sanciones
secundarias frost es por su positiva
integran con tipo dhruv ya nueve nuevos
ataques van a zhang se turna los líderes
europeos cerraron filas alegando que no
cederán al chantaje del gas a
europa y alemania pagarán en euros
algunos países pueden hacerlo en dólares
pero no en rublos
la presidenta de la comisión europea
señaló su intención de culminar la
dependencia de los combustibles fósiles
rusos
hoy el kremlin fracasó una vez más en su
intento de sembrar división entre los
estados miembros la era de los
combustibles fósiles rusos está llegando
a su fin en europa y europa avanza en
temas energéticos works on energy que
chus el portavoz del kremlin por su
parte amenaza con más cortes a futuro y
culpa a las naciones europeas de medidas
inamistosas contra su país por las
sanciones contra personas y empresas de
rusia y el apoyo a kiev en la guerra de
ucrania
la necesidad de esta nueva metodología
fue provocada por aquellas medidas sin
amistosas sin precedentes en la economía
y los sectores financieros que fueron
tomadas por naciones sin amistosas hacia
nosotros la dependencia del gas ruso
supera 50 por ciento en 14 países del
bloque europeo y rusia es el proveedor
de una veintena de naciones por lo que
en el seno de europa preocupa que si
gazprom lleva a cabo sus amenazas se
desate una crisis económica